one of the popular talking points that's
developed among the right-wing media
including fox news recently is that joe
biden is making gas prices higher by not
restarting construction of the keystone
xl pipeline and built into this entire
story
are misunderstandings about what the
keystone xl pipeline is and what it
would do how long it would take to
construct it as well as the degree to
which presidents impact gas prices
particularly when the the price of oil
is soaring globally
and and all of these things are being
missed with really kind of um uh it's
not even really pedantic they're they're
just
confused talking points from right
wingers one example that we're going to
look at right now is peter ducey from
fox news
for days ducey has been hammering
joe biden's white house press secretary
jen saki about gas prices and the
keystone xl pipeline and he seems to
understand very little about it not
surprisingly so let's look at his first
attempt uh from yesterday or his latest
attempt i guess we would call it from a
press briefing yesterday on this talking
point and then i'm going to tell you a
little bit about the truth about
keystone xl because there's a lot of
gray area here it is a restart of the
keystone xl construction
completely off the table as long as joe
biden is president well why don't you
tell me what that would help address
i'm asking you if it is an option you
guys say all options are on the table is
restarting keystone construction one of
them if we're trying to
bring about more supply that does not
address any problem it's supply from
canada a friendly ally instead of saudi
arabia that's already that's we're
already getting that oil peter it's the
the pipeline is just a delivery
mechanism it is not an oil field so it
does not provide more supply into the
system it does not address stable is it
possible that joe biden will ever
say
you guys can go ahead with construction
of keystone xl there's no plans for that
and it would not address any of the
problems we're having currently okay so
all of these right wingers talking about
keystone xl keystone xl first of all as
jen saki points out it's merely a
pipeline it's not a source of oil and
canadian oil is already coming into the
united states the pipeline in camp and
and here's the most important thing now
yesterday on my stream i asked people in
my in the audience do you guys realize
that phases one two and three of the
keystone xl pipeline are already up and
running when they talk about keystone xl
and when they talk about oh biden
stopped it and trump tried to do it and
obama stopped it do you guys realize
that it's just phase 4 of keystone xl 95
of my audience didn't know that
and that's by design when the right says
they've stopped keystone xl we're
getting no oil
phases one two and three of the keystone
xl pipeline are and have been up and
running it runs i believe from canada
from alberta to illinois and texas and
oklahoma these pipelines are already in
place what's at issue when people say
biden stopped it is biden stopped
construction of phase four and
there's controversy around phase four
because of how it would go through
indigenous land and the the indigenous
uh communities that would be affected uh
have not really been players at the
table in a way that many of us in the
united states think they should be so
obama delayed it and then trump tried to
resume that construction and then biden
stopped it and ultimately tc energy the
company in place has abandoned it so
first and foremost
keystone xl is up and running phase one
is up and running phase two is up and
running phase three is up and running
number two
uh it is not a method of supply it is a
method of transport
and number three
it would take probably years to complete
if you started that construction right
now and it would be a very modest amount
of oil relative to the total us need
it's a silly bogus talking point even if
biden said let's do phase four
it would not solve the problem right now
in any way
um do see continuing to just use these
confused different talking points here
trying to do a gotcha around
calling the gas price increases the
putin price hikes did you guys decide to
re-brand the rise and gas prices as the
hashtag putin price hike
i mean if you want to use that on fox i
welcome that but i think it'll get a lot
of air time because we have heard the
president warn for months the gas prices
were rising because of the supply chain
and because of post-pandemic demand if
you guys knew for months that this was
going to be the hashtag putin price hike
why aren't we just hearing that now
so of course i mean jen saki's answer
doesn't even matter again
gas prices can go up at different times
for different reasons and the
when remember when gas prices started
going up at the end of trump's
presidency
and they continued going up when joe
biden took over it was a global
phenomenon as a result of the resumption
and demand
with the easing of the pandemic we now
are seeing gas prices go up more
and it has to do with expectations
remember oil prices are sort of a
futures market it we are now seeing it
happen as a result of what's going on in
russia ukraine and for supply reasons
etc
all of these things can be true it's
sort of like if i wake up one day and i
have a headache because i didn't sleep
well
and then that night i bump my head and
the next day i have an even worse
headache it'd be like well why did you
why did you say it was because you were
tired on day one because you actually
bumped your head right on day one the
headache was because i was tired on day
two it was because i bumped my head
different causes can have a similar
effect one more example of the confusion
around this keystone xl thing here is
former obama economic advisor robert
wolf on fox news and he says this
keystone xl thing would not actually fix
the problem we're dealing with right now
and the fox anchor says well that's
debatable no it's not all right so if
that's not going to happen robert
perhaps as peter just reported perhaps
opening up the keystone pipeline is not
off the table for this white house what
did you take away from that
i think excel is off the table and let's
recall a few things one it's the worst
type of oil you can have it's tar sands
going from alberta to the gulf of mexico
it wasn't going to really change
anything to do with our oil supply it
was to export from the gulf of mexico
also recall that under president trump
well let me just okay it's not actually
debatable um
uh it has nothing to do with oil fields
it's a pipeline it was going to end the
gulf of mexico that's a fact you should
look it up yeah um this is the problem
you know how i've been saying to you
guys one of the problems we have right
now in american sort of in the media
milieu and in society in general is
people don't agree about what are facts
now
the the wording i'm using is very
important i'm not saying people don't
agree about what the facts are that
would be like i think you know i don't
know what the fact i think inflation's
gone up and you think it's gone down
okay whatever like that would be a
disagreement about the facts people
don't agree about what types of
statements are statements of fact the
keystone xl pipeline
is
something in particular it's not open to
opinion what the keystone xl pipeline is
or where it would have been or how much
oil it would have transported or whether
it's a source of oil or just a transport
method those are not opinions
those are things we can definitively
know
and the problem is when the fox news
anchor says well that's debatable
it's really not i mean you you can make
an argument that it's something else you
would be wrong it's not a statement of
opinion these are statements of fact and
just look at previous reporting about
the pipeline from when obama was
president um and uh that there are
actually reports from back then that say
phase four of keystone xl could actually
cause a gas price increase in the
midwest in particular because the oil
would be transported through there but
it's not intended for american consumers
the the reporting is out there so they
don't know as usual what the hell
they're talking about
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat we sometimes are combining
all sorts of different vitamins
supplements different things that may be
relevant to us ag-1 by athletic greens
is a delicious drink that just
simplifies the entire thing it's one
product you get all of the things you
need 75 vitamins minerals and whole food
sourced ingredients it's a multivitamin
it's a multi-mineral it's a probiotic
green food blend in one daily serving
really easy high quality bio-available
ingredients can fill those nutritional
gaps in your diet and they can help with
gut health and digestion and support you
in other ways and they can replace
multiple products and pills that you
might be taking it's just one drink
really simple i've been enjoying the ag1
drink by athletic greens tastes good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes